hello my name is Rohit tárrega
and in this session we'll be covering
Google clouds security privacy and
compliance solutions for healthcare I am
a product manager on the healthcare and
life sciences team within Google cloud
and my primary focus areas are
artificial intelligence security and
governance so before we get into any
specific technologies and solutions it
actually helps quite a bit to deep dive
into the you know healthcare and life
sciences market to understand the
regulatory landscape and the challenges
that organizations are facing so if we
look at 1 overview study on the
regulatory burden at hospitals and
health systems face they calculated a
significant financial and time cost to
compliance so in this report regulatory
compliance is not just you know the
security and privacy related aspects and
also covers areas like documentation
patient safety and others so if we look
at just IT compliance specifically you
know the information security privacy
compliance documentation of the
infrastructure that cost is still a
major component but it's not everything
that you see on this slide looking more
closely at the figures themselves across
the industry healthcare organizations
are spending approximately 39 billion
dollars a year in aggregate just on the
administrative activities of compliance
this presents a huge financial burden to
the organizations who need to be focused
on providing care and optimizing their
infrastructure as well the financial
cost isn't the only thing however there
are also approximately 59 full-time
employee equivalents dedicated to
regulatory compliance within an
average-size hospital this includes
approximately 15 or about a quarter of
which our clinical staff such as doctors
and nurses looking at the the patient
impact of both the financial aspects and
the clinician aspects the cost of
compliance results in material time
taken away from patient care and even
potentially creates redundant efforts
within an organization
so when we look through you know the
cloud provider technology one of the
things that we think about is how can
cloud technologies and cloud services
help reduce this burden of compliance
now where does this compliance
requirements come from unfortunately
there isn't one single answer that we
can tackle that addresses all compliance
requirements all security and privacy
requirements for an organization instead
we have to look at kind of the
amalgamation of different sorts of
regulatory frameworks industry standards
and other pressures healthcare
organizations face for compliance so the
first thing to to look into is data
privacy regulation this is highly
specific to a particular region such as
the u.s. the EU or even specific States
or you know counties or or provinces
however in general data privacy
regulation is a legal requirement
relating to data collection processing
and sharing the penalties for breaking
these data privacy regulations also
range they can vary from you know
financial penalties to lawsuits to
criminal cases depending on the specific
violation how severe it was
and what regulation is in question and
finally because these regulations are
meant to to stand through the test of
time they're generally not descriptive
you know you won't see specific
regulations say specific key lens for
encryption or exact technologies to use
but instead they're generally more
descriptive they'll say things like data
must be protected in the following ways
and and often there's no official
certification for these regulations
instead organizations have to ensure
that they're aligning to the letter and
spirit of the regulation but there is
room for some organizations specific
interpretation so if we look at you know
just one or two examples of data privacy
regulation in the u.s. the one that most
health care organizations are familiar
with is HIPAA and HIPAA is a regulation
again for the u.s. that covers the use
disclosure and security of
tected health information and protected
health information is a specific defined
category in HIPAA but essentially it's
it's patient information information
relating to the care of the patient any
bills they receive etc for HIPAA
specifically it applies to two types of
organizations in the u.s. covered
entities and business associates and
these categories just define how
healthcare organizations operate covered
entities are generally the point of care
the insurance companies the healthcare
data clearing houses and then the
business associates are any vendors or
partners of the covered entity that may
do data processing storage or
transmission on the on behalf of the
covered entity again as mentioned
there's no official certification for
HIPAA and the requirements are not very
prescriptive however they they do give a
general overview of how data should be
used collected protected stores and so
on there's another example of this one
you know in the EU that covers the
entire EU jurisdiction and covers some
foreign jurisdiction where EU citizen
data may be processed or it or
transmitted so in GDP are again you'll
see there's a parallel to HIPAA and that
it covers the scope processing and
transfer of personal data in this case
personal data includes some aspects of
healthcare data as well the GD P R does
not use the same language as HIPAA but
it says u GD P R is applicable to data
controllers and data processors there
again there is an exact parallel to
covered entities and business associates
under HIPAA but you can tell that
they're trying to segment the categories
of people who have collected and have
ownership of the data versus people who
have temporary access for a specific
case and finally again there's no
certification for GD P R and
organizations have to kind of align with
its guidance going into the next topic
the next topic is government frameworks
you can think of these as requirements
for contracting with government agencies
the penalties here are not
usually as severe as for the data
privacy regulation however they can
still be very material breach of
government frameworks can jeopardize
contracts with government agencies or it
can result in lawsuits to recoup any
damages here the certification
requirements are generally a bit more
prescriptive we'll go into a couple
examples later but unlike the data
privacy regulation which contained
general guidance government frameworks
tend to be very specific they can have
hundreds or thousands of specific
controls that an organization has to
implement test and document and there
are different degrees of compliance
depending on the framework so one common
example here again for a us-centric
view of things is called FedRAMP and
fred ramp is a US government requirement
for cloud service providers specifically
in order to allow the government agency
to purchase cloud provider solutions and
FedRAMP tends to be very prescriptive
and there are multiple levels of
compliance so organizations can meet you
know a number of different bars of
FedRAMP compliance which allows them to
operate certain workloads or sells
certain levels of technology to the US
government agencies there are you know a
lot of government frameworks depending
on where in the world you are which
government agencies you're working with
another example that comes up is the the
UK National Health Service toolkits and
these are you know guidelines for
technology outsourcing they're a little
bit less prescriptive than FedRAMP but
still more prescriptive than data
privacy regulation there is no official
certification here so you will see that
government frameworks tend to be a
little bit more varied on whether they
have an official certification path or
not another category of requirements
comes from industry standards and
industry standards tend to be committee
driven for a specific market or use case
most require an independent third party
audit it's not something that you can
gender
they self attest to within an
organization there has to be some sort
of checks and balances in place and in
you know most importantly participation
and industry standards is voluntary in
general but it's often enforced on a
contractual basis between a vendor and
their customer so there's no specific
penalties like there are for data
privacy regulation that you'd get from
the government specifically but you may
be susceptible to specific agreements
with your vendors or your customers
depending on what industry standards are
in scope for that relationship there are
a few examples here and most people are
generally familiar with the sock family
of standards and these are globally
recognized standards for IT operations
security availability confidentially
confidentiality integrity and so on this
is you know a very general purpose
standard that's that's useful for a lot
of technology providers across different
domains and then we can look at two
specific industry standard examples one
for healthcare and one for financial
services obviously these aren't mutually
exclusive there are financial services
organizations that operate in the
healthcare space so you know it's
important to understand that the domain
of the industry standard does not
necessarily map one to one with the
organizations that have to comply with
it as part of their business obligations
and the last thing to touch upon in this
session is good practice regulations and
good practice or GXP regulations are
actually a combination of government
regulation industry standard tribal
knowledge and other organizations
specific controls they tend to be more
nebulous for specific use cases however
some examples that are relevant to the
healthcare and life sciences industry
are good clinical practice good
laboratory practice and good
manufacturing practice there are some
common considerations for these various
GXP s often these they have similarities
in the configuration validation that
organ
patience have to do the contingency
planning process that organizations have
to have in place if a disaster were to
occur as well as access control and
audit trails to make sure that any
access to the system is properly
documented any changes are properly
validated and documented as well so this
is essentially the the summary of all of
the various regulatory and industry
standard frameworks that make up the IT
side of Healthcare Compliance and if you
take a closer look and distill all of
these various regulations and other
requirements relevant to the industry
you will see that there are quite a lot
of commonalities and this slide is meant
to indicate some of these commonalities
that healthcare organizations are facing
when it comes to setting up an
infrastructure and IT program so at the
infrastructure level the physical
machines the virtual machines the the
software running on the virtual machines
it's important that all of them all of
these various pieces are appropriately
hardened to protect against
vulnerabilities that may be appropriate
for that level of the stack so if we
think about network security one of the
common attacks that can take place is a
denial of service attack and protecting
this at the network level is appropriate
because it is fundamentally a network
and scaling a type of attack at the data
protection layer one of the common
protections is encryption and encryption
is applicable at this layer because you
want to make sure that the data that
resides on disk the data that's being
transmitted between various services and
even your backup systems has the proper
levels of encryption to protect against
vulnerabilities at the data storage
level and then if you keep moving up the
stack a lot of the industry standards
and regulatory frameworks also have
recommendations around Identity and
Access Management endpoint security how
we allow external users to connect to
your systems how you record accesses by
external users and make sure there's a
permanent audit trail and so on and so
forth so at this point it's important to
kind of transition to see ok how do we
move from the
general scope of requirements into
something that is specific to Google
cloud and and specifically implementing
secure private and compliant workloads
on Google cloud the first thing that's
important to discuss when talking about
cloud is the shared responsibility model
and specifically the shared
responsibility model in in detail the
the shared responsibility model says
that in contrast to traditional IT
systems where the IT owner is
responsible for maintaining the
infrastructure stack top to bottom with
cloud services that responsibility is
shared between the cloud provider and
the in-house IT team of the organization
and it's beneficial from multiple angles
the shared responsibility model allows
each organization to focus on their
specific projects and core competencies
while Google the cloud provider focuses
on managing the services and the
underlying infrastructure and this can
be from a security standpoint from a
scaling standpoint from a freshness of
the IT stack so to speak making sure
that the machines are up-to-date and
replaced periodically and there are
other benefits from this model as well
it allows organizations to benefit from
Google's world-class security and
privacy teams who are in charge of
maintaining the infrastructure and you
can also take advantage of the cost
savings that stem from Google's ability
to purchase these technologies in bulk
and efficiently manage the data center
environments and delivering the cloud
services so on this diagram you can see
that different levels of services have
different levels of responsibilities
related to security privacy and
compliance and this is generally a
function of how much control the cloud
service user has over the environment so
in an infrastructure as a service or is
service you'll see that there is a fair
amount of responsibility that the
customers IT team still has to manage
but this is also reflected in the level
of control that their IT team has over
the system so if there are requirements
to have a specific guest OS image
you know a specific network topography a
specific level of encryption using
specific key lengths specific encryption
algorithms that level of control comes
with the comparable level of
responsibility to do things
appropriately and therefore you'll see
that the cloud provider Google cannot
manage as much of the system as they can
in other services so when we move kind
of up the stack into more manage
services let's say a platform as a
service offering you can see that the
level of responsibility managed by the
cloud provider increases and this is to
reflect that the cloud provider is now
taking more of the decisions and
responsibilities around scaling security
compliance and providing a managed
service to the user and finally at the
the right-hand side with a
software-as-a-service application the
cloud provider has taken on a majority
of the responsibility in maintaining the
service and then the user only generally
has to worry about what data they put in
the application who they share access
with and so on and so forth so there's a
column missing in this diagram and
that's kind of the traditional IT model
the for cloud services and and that
would be where an organization's
in-house IT team or outsource IT team
was responsible for all of these
activities related to cloud to the
security of the platform and that would
be a fully blue column so to speak so
you can see that even in you know the
most flexible cloud services there's
still a decent amount of responsibility
that the cloud provider is managing so
let's take a look at some specific
examples it related to Google cloud if
we look at a hypothetical shared
responsibility matrix for compute engine
which is our infrastructure as a service
compute platform you'll see that at the
bottom of the stack Google takes full
responsibility for the hardware
underlying the service and we implement
that using our proprietary hardware
stack we also take responsibility for
the boot process the kernel the storage
and encryption at the physical layer as
well as the network
again on the physical site and this is
done through Google's proprietary
technology and hardware stack to make
sure that you know the vulnerabilities
are mitigated attacks can be prevented
and and/or mitigated and that google has
taken responsibility for the security
and compliance of these components
turning focus to the customer
responsibilities they start pretty much
at the anything that is installed on the
virtual machine so the guest OS the
choice of OSS is with the user what data
they put on the machine is up to the
user how they configure the network how
they authenticate users to the system
basically how they scale the virtual
machines up and down depending on
traffic going to the application and
then all the way up to the top of the
stack what web services run on the
virtual machine so there's a there's a
lot of freedom afforded to the users of
compute engine to configure and manage
their applications appropriately but
that also comes with the responsibility
to do it correctly
transitioning to a platform service such
as bigquery you can automatically see
that Google's responsibility has moved
up the stack so to speak Google is now
responsible specifically for maintaining
the operations of the service and what
that means is bigquery scales
automatically for the amount of data
that customers put in the platform so
Google is handling you know adding more
memory to the system adding more storage
adding more compute capacity and
customers do not have to but there is
still customer responsibility here and
the responsibility again goes from which
users have access to these bigquery
instances and bigquery data sets all the
way up to what applications are able to
manipulate data in bigquery going to the
the far end of the spectrum an example
of a SAS platform in Google cloud is
Google Drive and a hypothetical shared
responsibility matrix for this shows
that Google's responsibility moves quite
far up the stack Google is now
responsible for deploying the service in
an in a way that customers can
appropriately access and
but customers again will always retain
some level of responsibility for
choosing what content they put into the
service who is able to access it within
the customer's organization and so on so
if we summarize Google's technology
suite for helping customers with their
shared responsibilities you'll see that
Google has products and services to help
with shared responsibilities in all of
these areas so on the infrastructure
side there are things like shielded VMs
which can help protect the
infrastructure as a service offerings
there are services like data loss
prevention and VPC service controls that
can help these platform-as-a-service
Services manage their data appropriately
and access controls appropriately and
then finally at the top of the stack
even with regards to SAS services there
are endpoint security and Identity and
Access Management solutions to make sure
that access is appropriately controlled
to a SAS application even though the
customer is not responsible for managing
anything below a certain level in that
stack and finally in in regards to the
overview of Google Cloud I mentioned
earlier that there were a number of
government regulations frameworks
industry standards that were relevant to
healthcare and life sciences here is an
overview of Google clouds overall
compliance posture this is not you know
an exhaustive list of everything
customers can do on Google cloud but it
is a representation of frameworks at
Google Cloud 'dearest - some of which
have self attestation some of which have
external third-party attestation and
some of which have specific contractual
indicators as well so at this point I
want to transition focus to setting up
and managing healthcare workloads on
Google cloud and specifically how you
can best manage your shared
responsibilities and add ear to the
various security privacy and compliance
requirements that you need - and one of
the offerings that we have in the space
is called the
health care data protection suite and
the healthcare data protection suite is
an integrated tool for deploying
monitoring and auditing Google cloud
environments and workloads that are
running on Google cloud and by
integrated I mean there is very little
lag between the deployment of the
resources themselves when they start
getting monitored and when they're the
monitoring data is available for
investigation
triage documentation and so on how this
works at a technical level we have
integrated infrastructure as code
deployment templates command line tools
and continuous integration continuous
deployment pipelines to enable easy
verifiable and reproducible deployment
of Google cloud architectures as well as
common healthcare and life sciences
solutions so what this means is we have
some predefined templates for common
healthcare workloads on Google cloud
such as HIPAA aligned deployments or Rd
platforms that account for various
compliance guidance as well as technical
best practices for setting up Google
cloud services and there is a automation
for this deployment there's automation
for validating that everything in these
in Frye's code templates was deployed
appropriately and then there is
continuous monitoring against a set of
defined policies that are defined at the
time of resource creation and having
this suite fully integrated means that
you can define your workload and the
monitoring policy is side-by-side you
can ensure there's no or minimal gaps in
monitoring coverage and start scanning
for policy violations as soon as the
resources are deployed and this is a you
know a little bit more useful than some
other tool suites where the monitoring
deployment and auditing are all separate
steps in some of those other workflows
the to environment gets deployed there
can often be a lag of several hours to
several weeks between when the resources
are deployed and when they begin to be
monitored and then another lag between
the monitoring data is available and
when it's available for triage and
investigation in any sort of UI
interface so if we take a look at how
this works in detail there is a suite of
configuration libraries that we've made
available to our users and what these
allow users to do is create deployment
modules you can have deployment modules
for specific services like bigquery
Google Cloud storage and compute engine
that tell the application how these
services should be configured where they
should be set up what the IAM policy
should look like what the monitoring
rules should look like and then these
are all stored in the form of a
declarative template and once this
template is ready to be deployed we have
integration with terraform for
continuous deployment continuous
integration and automation of the
deployment practices and and what this
allows you to do is you know do your
code reviews on automation code you
don't have to wait for the environment
to be set up to do the validation it
also helps you set up multiple instances
of the exact same infrastructure for
different purposes so you can imagine
potentially some GXP related
requirements where you have to have
identical production development and
test or QA environments and this
automated template framework allows you
to set these up exactly equal to each
other you don't have to rely on making
sure you click the right buttons in the
console or run the right command-line
arguments in the same order every time
diving deeper into these templates the
deployment templates can be written in a
native terraform syntax or in our own
declarative llamó syntax that compiles
in to terraform and different
organizations may have different
preferences for how they use these tools
organizations that have terraform code
already can reuse that or organizations
that don't have existing terraform code
and prefer a declarative llamó syntax
can start there and generate the
terraform output as I mentioned these
deployment templates are modular they
can be
linked together to make larger projects
or organization structures for the
workloads and they also have accounted
for resource specific configuration so
where a specific resource has a
configuration parameter you can account
for that specifically and not have to
set it you know globally after
deployment so this example on the slide
is setting up a project for holding data
and what this is doing is its setting up
a bigquery data set with a data
retention policy to map the specific
privacy or compliance requirement it
sets a data viewer group as well as a
project owner group that has access to
all of the resources within a project
and and and essentially once this
template is deployed it will result in a
bigquery data set with all the
appropriate settings and controls on it
and leaning on from this the resource
deployment feeds directly into the
monitoring policies and the monitoring
policies can be auto-generated based on
the deployment template so where there
is a setting for i.m policy in the
deployment template the tools can infer
that you might want a monitoring policy
to prevent changes to that iam
configuration or the monitoring policies
can also be explicitly specified so if
you have a very specific set of
allowable
contractual requirements with your
customers and any one of those settings
is allowed you can set a monitoring
policy that allows you to set any one of
those configurations but not deviate
from that approved set by default the
scanners for these monitoring controls
run at a default 12 hour interval
however this can be configured to any
interval that you're comfortable with in
your organization the examples of
available monitoring policies are
centered around compliance requirements
specifically the security and privacy
compliance requirements and some
examples are access control lists and
iam policies ensuring that your
on it logging settings are appropriate
making sure that the api's that have
been enabled in your project are
appropriate for what that project will
be doing with data and going you know
further down the list if there are
specific data retention requirements or
data lifecycle requirements those can be
monitored for as well so the example on
the left side is showing how to
explicitly specify monitoring
requirements in the configuration
interface and what this is doing here is
showing that there's two controls that
are being monitored for one is the
policy member domains which you are
allowed to have membership within the
food domain or the bar domain for
example and then the allowed shared VPC
host projects which are declared beneath
and what these monitoring rules will do
is if there's any deviation from you
know the two named policy member domains
or the two VPC shared host projects you
will get an alert in the monitoring
toolset that it claims that there has
been a deviation and finally the last
step in this integrated process is the
auditing and reporting so the the data
protection dashboard here enables users
to visualize track policy violations
captured by these monitoring tools you
can dig into the policy violations view
the the scan results in raw detail as
well as understand long term and short
term policy violation trends and and
having this suite fully integrated helps
maintain the context all the way from
deployment to the end of the process
which is auditing all the way back to
starting over with with redeployment or
iterations on top so this an example of
a GCP environment deployed with the data
protection suite is this HIPAA aligned
deployment you can see that there's a
connection to an on-prem interface that
helps bring data to and from Google
Cloud there's a networking project that
manages the the interconnects the
routing the firewall rules between the
the on-prem and the cloud environment
and then there's two cloud projects one
is for hosting the data and application
them itself and one is for the security
operations that run the monitoring tools
as well as the auditing UI so this can
be deployed in just a couple hundred
lines of configuration and setup within
an organization in a few minutes and
this is in contrast to the several days
or weeks it would take to get the same
environment set up and validated through
more manual means so wrapping up on the
the data protection suite the main
benefits here are accelerated migration
time line decrease time to realizing the
value of cloud and pre applying the best
practices for security and compliance if
we look at one other area of Google
cloud that helps organizations meet
their privacy compliance requirements
specifically its D identification D
identification is the removal of
personally identifying information from
data such that you can no longer
identify the individuals that the data
or data set links to but that the data
retains utility for research and
commercial development purposes and both
aspects are important right because it's
important to maintain patient privacy
but also not delete the research value
of the data set in the process D
identification is important because it
can prepare data for applications that
are outside of the traditional clinical
domain and some examples of this are
ensuring that data is private for
analytics for sharing securely with
other organizations and for using an
application development the
identification is an important aspect of
several privacy regulations and one of
those is HIPAA so revisiting HIPAA it
allows for using de-identified data in
secondary use cases obviously there are
certain limitations here but for the
most part once data is due you
identified and provably de-identified it
is available for use outside of the
clinical
workflow and HIPAA defines a couple
different approaches to claiming that
data sets are de-identified one is
expert determination and the other is
safe harbor it's important to note that
while these different approaches have
different benefits depending on whether
the data set is structured
semi-structured or unstructured neither
method is definitively guaranteed to
eliminate a reaiiy denta fication risk
so looking at the identifier is that
HIPAA is most interested in specifically
for the safe harbor approach you'll see
that there's kind of 18 categories that
are important to consider most of them
are fairly straightforward and easy to
interpret why they may be personally
identifying such as names telephone
numbers fax numbers email addresses
websites faces and so on there are also
some identifiers that on the surface may
not be immediately identifying such as
zip codes or cities as well as some
other aspects but you can imagine that
if a zip code is small enough or there
are a few enough people within a
particular zip code that statistically
it could be used to indicate a subset of
population that the data may belong to
so that's that's why HIPAA tends to have
opinions on geographic location D
identification this slide kind of shows
the the value of maintaining research
value of a data set during the
identification if we look at the example
on the Left we can see that somebody's
social security number is in this
message as well as their phone number
and their name and then on the right
side there are three different levels of
D identification the first level is just
included for completeness it's
essentially deleting all of the data we
have fully de-identified this message
but we've also eliminated its research
value the second example shows how to
remove all of the PII but also at the
same time remove all of the utility of
this example the bottom example is
retains some of the PII specifically the
name and the phone number but it
moves the especially sensitive PII of
the social security number and in this
case this example is is the most useful
for completing the task that needs to be
done here in this case helping the
patient get an appointment scheduled but
also ensuring that they're sensitive PII
is not overexposed with the social
security number so there are tools on
Google cloud to help with the
identification the healthcare API is our
data platform for health care data in
standardized formats such as fire and
DICOM this service has an integrated D
identification tool that can be used for
D identifying datasets than joining and
exporting them to things like machine
learning models or analytics and NBI
tools and this is you know when you want
to analyze an entire data set in batch
there is also the ability to process
individual records through the D
identification workflow and this can be
useful for real-time applications like
viewers or patient data applications
where patients and providers are
interacting in real-time with each other
this is a quick example of how the D
identification tools work the fire
format is a mixture of structured and
unstructured data in a key-value format
so you can see that there's some
structured PII
on the left side in this original fire
record and there's also some
unstructured PII at the very bottom
through the D identification tools the
fire record has been processed the
structured fields have been removed or
transformed as have the unstructured
fields for organizations that want a
specific method of D identification done
but also don't necessarily have the
technical abilities in-house to do so we
have a program that pairs partner
services with customers to perform some
of these D identification activities and
this can help customers get access to
de-identified and validated data without
necessarily needing to hire specific
technical or privacy skills in-house and
with that it's a it's a good segue to
say that
there are partners available for all
aspects of the security and privacy
compliance workflows not just the
identification this slide shows a quick
picture overview of some of our partners
in this space many of whom you may
already have relationships with so it's
important to note that there is a large
partner ecosystem on Google cloud for
the healthcare industry when it comes to
security and privacy compliance and with
that thank you for joining this session
I hope you learned something useful